set against the tumultuous backdrop of
the 1967 new york riots the many saints
of newark is a prequel to the sopranos
hbo's smash hit prestige tv series that
became a cultural phenomenon when it
debuted back in 1999 the film is
co-written by david chase who created
the original sopranos series and its
colorful cast of characters starring
james gandolfini's son michael
gandolfini as young tony soprano the
many saints of newark chronicles the
formative years of tony as a kid and a
teenager and the impactful relationship
he shared with his mob boss uncle dickie
moltesanti as fans well know it would
not exactly be a spoiler to say that
young tony grows up to follow in uncle
dicky's footsteps so how does this
improbable prequel end does the ending
serve as a logical prologue to the
sopranos or is it telling its own story
simply set in david chase's universe the
opening shot gently pans over a gloomy
graveyard getting closer and closer to
what is revealed to be christopher's
grave yes that christopher in the first
few shots of the movie the audience
hears the voice of christopher
moltesanti telling the story from beyond
the grave since christopher is a baby in
the time period that many saints takes
place he hardly factors into the prequel
story tony exclaims that his baby nephew
only ever cries when he is around pretty
deftly foreshadowing their tumultuous
future relationship which takes a
murderous turn during the timeline of
the sopranos
some babies when they come into the
world know all kinds of things from the
other side
these little referential treats aside
the story of many saints doesn't really
turn out to be about tony or christopher
by the end it's got a lot more to do
with the man whose shadow extends over
their relationship for decades to come
christopher's father dickie moltzanti
while the movie is mostly framed through
young tony's point of view as he
experiences the chaos and violence
surrounding him and his family the story
is really more focused on the trials and
tribulations of dickie maltsanti's life
in an interview with the hollywood
reporter director alan taylor said it
was important to feel tony powerfully in
the movie even though structurally it's
dicky's story this certainly seems to
suggest that the focus on dickie is just
as the creators intended this is part of
the reason christopher narrates instead
of our present day point of view
character young tony tony's environment
and his pivotal bond with dickie
essentially morphs him into the new
jersey mob boss that he infamously
becomes but many saints isn't really a
tony soprano origin story at the crux of
the film are the tensions between the
white and black residents of new york
new jersey after a black man is killed
by the new york police a real-life
incident that resulted in uprisings that
nearly burned the city down the
generational conflict between the mob
and the black community is a constant
presence in many states with the
heightened racial tensions serving as
more setting than plot point this
ambient tension is made manifest in the
story via the looming conflict between
dickie and a black man named harold
mcbrayer with whom he used to do
business when mcbrayer turns against
sticky for killing one of his own an
all-out war ensues between the two rival
factions of new york it becomes a
bloodbath between the italian mob and
mcbrayer and his crew if racial and
cultural tensions were always simmering
beneath the surface on the sopranos they
claim top billing in the plot of many
saints even though the film is a period
piece this choice makes it feel current
and culturally relevant and may even
provide a fresh lens through which to
revisit the sopranos interestingly the
film's culminating act of violence isn't
an act of racial animus but rather a
manifestation of the conflicts within
the italian mob this dynamic too will be
familiar to fans of the sopranos no
matter how many threats attack from the
outside it's always the threats from
within that prove the most deadly toward
the end of the film in a surprise twist
dickie is suddenly shot and killed by
someone who is revealed to have been
hired by junior soprano tony's uncle and
a member of the family who has always
been at odds with dickie earlier dickie
even humiliates junior in a very public
way by laughing at him when he falls
down the stairs at dicky's father's
funeral it's interesting to consider the
ways this struggle between junior and
dickie replays a generation later
between junior and tony junior tries to
kill tony in season one you'll recall
and how this twist reveals the truth
about barry haydu the retired cop who
christopher thinks killed his father
because tony convinced him of this and
who christopher murders in his home at
the start of season four
you're being set up
he's lying to you whoever he is
at dickie's funeral tony stands staring
at dicky in the open casket he imagines
himself making a pinky swear with dickie
it's a call back to a moment earlier in
the film but more importantly it
foreshadows the way tony will continue
dickie's legacy check out one of our
newest videos right here plus even more
looper videos about your favorite new
movies are coming soon subscribe to our
youtube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]